three-year-old kamani watson derby was
on his way home for the last time
his mother had just taken him to the gp
because he'd been vomiting
a nurse had diagnosed a stomach bug but
failed to spot the broken ribs or note
the bruises on his face and body
for weeks the one smiling toddler had
been regularly beaten at the flat in
west bromwich where he lived with his
mother and her partner he'd be locked in
a room secured with electrical cables so
he couldn't get out
he used to tell his dad he didn't want
to go home
these images are the last of him alive
that afternoon he was hit so hard he
suffered a fatal internal bleed
his mother called for an ambulance
um yeah but he's not responding to me
he's free he's three
he's three years old he's three years
old he's not responding no
by the time paramedics arrived here
kamani was already lifeless he was taken
to hospital but pronounced dead later
that day
he was a bubbly
friendly
you know little one
is taking its toll on the rest of the
family his grandmother blames her
daughter's relationship with nathaniel
pope
everything was fine before he come along
everything was fine
until when him come
everything changes he's evil and twisted
and cold
is cold-hearted
we now know kamani's nursery and family
had asked about injuries his mother
would say he was clumsy
opportunities missed to save this little
boy becky johnson sky news west bromwich